the Joe Rogan experience so suck my dick
I'm gonna go thank you got a 50% but I'm
looking up they're trying new [ __ ] last
night I was talking about that we've
always men at one time or another me
toots somebody that's how you learn not
to be a meat or is by me doing somebody
one time and then you go that wasn't
right and then I'll never meet two again
for me I was weird adjectives all I
started out with it I opened up with it
to really put myself in the [ __ ] hole
of death unless that there was an adverb
what is that meat cooing is it a verb if
you meet you somebody has to be an
adverb yeah second yeah the only way you
learned out of me the only way you learn
how to not beat me to meet Torah is by
me to it you shoplift a candy when you
were a kid right yeah and your mother
told you smack nice because that's not
right same thing with me doing this la
is a [ __ ] me too was invented here
they [ __ ] Marilyn's Martin Monroe to
death they [ __ ] under death a vaginal
thing looks like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
Embassy in Tehran whatever they bombed
what was that famous Fatty Arbuckle case
where there was a disgusting people yes
you know between the Bikram documentary
did you see that one I didn't see that
filthy [ __ ] animal getting women to
suck that [ __ ] this 90 degree weather
6co recession dick
that's just cruelty to animals you could
put you in jail for just sucking that
desk you know Harvey all that [ __ ]
happens here but as us as men we've all
made some money when you were a kid by
mistake to me I was in love with this
lady named fate she was 37 at big juicy
tits she'd wear hot pants I was about 14
I had never even seen him a giant and no
titties nothing and we used to play
basketball my two dogs were blind
she had French poodles and she had
flip-flops and she crossed the street
and she was so hot she was 38 and she
had a husband that was like 60 he would
just barely be alive like that dude from
Texas that was [ __ ] Howard Marshall I
he would watch her cuz he knew he was
savage fool I think adapt
she had two daughters and the daughters
were badass and but one of my goombas
dated one of the daughters I never told
him I was alive each time I play
basketball failure would come on the
game would you stop and she turned for
us and the Sun would shine through a
halt and I'm a halter top in the
seventies and she had a really yummy
Teddy's with the nipple stick another
girl me crazy I was 13 14 I little that
I'd see her in the window with pants on
she looked delicious and finally summer
of [ __ ] 79 I'm getting all [ __ ] up
with some friends of mine we're drinking
[ __ ] nips we should not have some
angel dust and we'll listen to Led
Zeppelin - if you're gonna [ __ ] his
buddy Led Zeppelin - is the album to get
yours it starts off with a whole lot of
love that just gets your hips moving and
then it goes until the lemon song and
he's talking about squeeze me baby - the
juice runs down my leg I'm like that's
it the juice is running down my leg
my mother was a flower chicks yet
flowers everywhere
I put on like a shirt I swear to god it
had to be about that because she would
walk the dog at night but the husband
told you the time 15 the dog would sleep
that the husband would pass out by 8:00
so she would take the dogs out for the
10 o'clock the last she would put him
down and you know they were kind of
blind French poodles and she was still
wearing a [ __ ] tighty whities you
know the dance Dixie dudes days in the
70s before days even it was invented she
already had the Daisy on with the shirt
and I remember being on that angel dust
hiding in the weeds one second like
[ __ ] and with the flowers had flowers
for I was gonna bring her flowers but my
plan was to attack her like this jumper
in the thing throw it down and give her
the flowers this is how crazy he was
gonna attack her like I couldn't take it
no more like I wanted to marry her like
that's how [ __ ] up out anywhere not an
angel dust and I was on Ange of this it
was what I would tease see crystal call
it what you want it's animal
tranquilizer
no matter how you look at it
and I remember that I ran upon her and
she turned and she goes Coco what's
going on I go and I just stopped and I
go fight I'm in love with you
and she said what are you talking about
on my fare been in love with you for two
years I want to run off with you [ __ ] my
mother I'm like I just let's get a job
let's let's leave Wow
and she's looking at me like wait a lot
like I was [ __ ] first of all she's
thinking me like this kid is [ __ ]
snapped and she goes you've been
drinking and like I still love you take
the flowers and she goes I'll tell you
what if I divorced my husband I'll
consider it
and I was like okay I'll live with that
can I give you a kiss I like kissed her
on the cheek I like to feel the heat
going up my head and finally as I went
to turn away I looked at her like she
had the juiciest legs in the world I
know can I touch your thigh and she goes
go ahead Jerome and that's like her
kneecap and my dick just exploded that
sperm I ran away like Stephen stood out
the embassy Stevenson got run he runs
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] put that little
limp in Steven Seagal run
[Applause]